- Let's finish out strong
with a story I hope will warm your heart.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
A PE coach in Portland,
Oregon is making sure
kids at his school get to
feel the joy and freedom
of riding their bikes.
He started what he calls a bike bus.
Once a week, a hundred plus
kids take over the streets
riding their bicycles to school.
(upbeat funky music)
(audience applauds)
Looks awesome, right?
We have this fearless leader
and educator on the line now
watching on Fox 12 Oregon at three.
Hi!
Hi, Coach Balto.
Happy to have you.
So how did you come up with it?
- So as a physical education teacher,
I've always been passionate
about finding ways
for children to be physically active,
and children walking and biking to school
is a great way to build physical activity
into their schedule.
I saw videos in Barcelona
and in San Francisco
of bike buses last school year.
So I organized bike bus for Earth Day.
It was a huge success.
They love it so much.
They're asking for bikes
for their birthday,
and they're even biking
on non bike bus days.
It's absolutely incredible to see.
- I love it.
It's really powerful,
and you do them every
week, right, without fail?
- Every week rain or
shine every Wednesday.
We have two routes a mile
and a half from each other,
and then they meet a mile from the school,
and that's where the fun really takes off.
We have a group of
awesome parent volunteers
who join us and ride to
make sure everybody's safe,
and neighbors come out and
they cheer the students
when they ride by while
we're blasting fun music.
Children now more than ever
are craving social connection.
and this is a great way
to get the kids active.
And the great thing about this,
this is a movement anybody can create
in their school community.
Find another family to ride bikes with,
organize a bike bus, share
it with other people.
Even if it's a two block ride,
it's a great time and you'll
see the joy that bikes create.
- Love it.
Thanks for being an
amazing community leader.
Thank you so much, Coach Balto.
I'm liking your post right now.
That's not all.
Kelly's season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate educators like you
giving their all to their students.
So they're giving Alameda
Elementary PTA $1,000.
(audience applauds)
Amazing.
- Amazing. Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much to all our guests today.
Ryan Reynolds, Will Ferrell,
and Octavia Spencer,
and Angela Bassett.
As Kelly always says, have a great day.
And if it's not, change it.